it isn't just text messages hurting the
legitimacy of mothers investigation of
course the FBI is in infamous reliance
on the Trump dossier is doing a good job
as well
Republican congressman Ron De Santis of
Florida says that use of the dossier
undermines the basic legitimacy of the
FBI's warrant to investigate the Trump
campaign following last year's election
and congressman De Santis
joins us now this is a very interesting
legal point you made if this dossier was
the pretext for the entire investigation
it's a it's a kind of almost absurd
fruits of the poisonous tree thing in
that it's not it's it's not a legitimate
pretext for an investigation is that
correct yeah and just think about where
this dossier came from this was paid for
by Hillary Clinton the Democratic Party
they paid millions of dollars to Perkins
called law firm who then laundered it to
Fuzion GPS so you have fusion GPS
producing this thing I think Christopher
Steele was more of a cover to make it
look like an intelligence product but to
this day the FBI can't verify anything
in it other than one person associated
with Trump travel to Russia at some
point so this stuff is bogus it's fake
news and you expect that kind of stuff
to be generated in the course of a
political campaign but if that is
presented to the FBI and then they're
taking that that unverified dossier and
launching a federal counterintelligence
investigation without anything more to
me that raises some serious questions
and was it Peter struck who was involved
remember that the key text message was
he was in and Rubik Abe's office and
they were talking about Lisa Paige said
Oh Donald Trump can't win and struck
says you know I don't think the FBI can
take that risk we need an insurance
policy basically against Trump's
election so the question is was that
dossier and the subsequent investigation
and surveillance the insurance policy he
referenced in those text messages and
and what you're saying here is that
it comes before a FISA judge who isn't
an expert in intelligence matters but
it's got the FBI imprimatur it's it's
kind of got an mi6 imprimatur because
the spook appears to have credentials
and and and in a sense it would appear
to be a plausible document if laid
before a judge is that correct well
that's the question you know we've asked
the Department of Justice the FBI to
give us the information about how the
dossier got in their possession
did they pay for the dossier and how did
they use the dossier
did they use it as the basis to get
these FISA warrants and they've
basically refused to answer those
questions this has got to come to a head
because I think you're gonna see a
contempt of Congress if they don't
produce this in the Intelligence
Committee but that's the question and
here's the thing mark if the answer to
all those questions was no then they
would just say no the fact that they
haven't to me raises some serious
questions
well well you've said that they've been
looking at this thing for a year and a
half now and Christopher steel cooked it
up in a few weeks they've been unable to
corroborate anything except that some
guy at some point got on a plane to
Russia but they don't know what he did
once he got off the plane in Russia how
many more months or years do they need
to supposedly attempt to corroborate
this nonsense look I think it's time to
put up or shut up this this whole thing
started you know obviously after struck
and these guys started the
counterintelligence when Muller got
appointed I think Rosen Stein made a big
mistake because what he was doing was he
was superimposing a criminal prosecutor
on top of a counterintelligence
investigation and and how how good of an
investigation that was obviously there's
a lot of concern about that but there's
never been a crime identified here you
can believe that Russia tried to hack
different people's email accounts but
that doesn't mean that there was a
criminal conspiracy with Trump's
campaign and there's never been
information provided to substantiate
that so I think if he can't answer that
question then I think we need to move on
I
you are going to see the committees and
Congress move on and I think the result
is going to be no collusion yeah that
makes a lot of sense congressman thanks
thanks for that